behind every successful man is a woman
so that's
that's the topic of the day so what i
want to do is real quick just get your
when i hear you when i you hear me say
that what's the first thing that comes
to mind mr sapology go ahead first yes
100 yes i've been on both sides i've
been married divorced and married
remarried again and i got married when i
was a little bit older in life more
mature and
a little bit more financially ahead
whereas before i was in the military the
marine corps you know you know military
weddings yeah i do right
military ways to get married because we
make extra yeah money and when you get
married you get off base and that money
had a lot to do with getting married
that'd be a really especially when
you're broke
you know because you would shack up
together and
and so um
i didn't realize that
a woman in your life
in my
young twininess was all about
90 sex
okay i i'll i'll admit that but the more
i realized [ __ ] i got to wake up this
person you gotta deal with this friend
oh had a kid
i got to deal with this person oh values
and principles are starting to come out
oh the way you were raised is different
that was there's oh the way we handle
money is
damn
so in one year
saucy i got married come here from the
deployment yep i got married
divorced
had a kid
found bankruptcy it was my motivational
year of change
1995 1996. gotcha yeah lifetime ago yeah
it's all documented orange county
california you can see all there and
and uh 14 years after that i just went
into complete
let me just figure myself out gotcha so
matt's answer is definitely yes
definitely yes okay if it's the right
woman though it's the right word clearly
all right so there's a caveat that
correct derek
do you have a different opinion on this
because you don't have a relationship
right now what's your status what are
your thoughts on this i'm single i'm
single um
my my opinion on this is
yes a successful man
would have a woman in fact some
successful men have
have multiple women have multiple women
a lot of times when people hear that
that contacts they they
in a way it's too
i personally believe in a way it's to
kind of not give the man his full credit
in a sense it's like yeah he's a
successful man
but hey you wouldn't be successful with
that without his woman yeah but we have
to think we have to think about the fact
that is um
most of the time that woman's with that
man because he's already successful oh
let me say that uh she likes a lot of
time women will wait at the finish line
to pick the winner right that's kind of
what you're saying here right or either
he would have some sort of he would he
would have some sort of drive
ambition he'd be in some sort of
direction on becoming successful so she
would say hey i see that successful man
and whatnot okay
so a little bit different of an answer
caveat so let's ask the lovely woman on
the panel
well first i wanted to talk with derek
for a little bit because he said
successful and multiple women yeah
that's in a sentence that doesn't really
make sense
only because um
when you have multiple women or three
women for women you are not being
focused right and the successful if
you're not focused you are not going to
be successful so just two women with a
successful men
i don't know to me they're just confused
at that point do you think if a man has
multiple women
it um
gives him more value because he's able
to have multiple women no it depends on
what we consider value right like we're
not thinking that just because you have
multiple women it's value
that's not a value to have or that
people should embrace so you have an
issue with multiple women
that's and that's totally wrong but then
you're right and it's very controversial
especially with men no it's not
controversial it's not controversial you
don't think so it's why is it not
controversial here's why i've been i've
been on both sides of that too as well
i've had game yeah right and thank god
social media was not around in the 90s
that's the ball of dropping gems
was that me answering for a lot of stuff
today yeah i mean because today you
don't ever know when the camera's on
yeah somebody's wrong cameras are
rolling by the way right now cameras
i would just say though having uh
multiple women
creates a lot of attention elsewhere
she doesn't get 100 of you and guess
what flip the opposite is true she can
have multiple guys too as well and do
you feel okay with that and
it's expensive
uh you have to remember what you said to
this person oh the worst part when you
call another woman the other woman's
name oh
by the way you know this reminds me
exactly there's a quote kanye says he
goes i don't know what's better getting
paid or getting late i know when i'm
focusing on one the other's getting away
right that's kind of what you're saying
here but you disagree though derek
yes i i disagree you disagree with matt
and with kanye it's okay it's okay it's
all good bring it baby and with you
well it's an army thing just a rebuttal
about what eurena was talking about
what
him having multiple women what does it
really have to do with his success
because these women aren't going to be
in these offices
you know signing things these women
aren't going to be there saying hey you
should you should do this or do that so
explain more on that no what i'm trying
to say is that when a man is focused
when they have a goal right they will
work towards that goal and when you are
focusing on multiple things at a time
multi-tasking which we think
multitasking is good now
but it's actually hurting us right
because it our energy is going to
multiple different streams versus where
you should be focused in one so
being successful and having multiple
women that's not what i measure should
what i meant measure success with like i
really don't so that brings me back to
my answer was to it's a woman behind a
man's success to me and then again it's
how do we define success what does that
mean to you right to me
a successful man i see that on the
product that i have raised like like
what type of family they have raised to
me that's how i measured success money
of course but now i'm a millionaire
myself so it's very easy to make money
the so what i thought like so what i
don't want to put words in your mouth
but the quote um
behind every successful man is a woman
if you could rewrite that as a
successful woman what would you want
that quote to be because you're a female
you're successful what would you want
that quote to be
no i think it's great i just think it
doesn't apply to everything right of
course you have to have a woman because
if you have a strong woman then you
don't have to worry about home and your
children and how your children are being
raised well no i i want to stay right
there for a second because i want to get
to something
whoever made that quote
do you think it was a man or woman that
made that quote probably a woman
so but if you as a successful woman like
i don't want to put words in your mouth
but if you're like behind every
successful woman is a man who
falls in line something like that is
there something that
falls in line that they would be like
you know
they're fi you know i don't like that
that's what what would you be that's
what i'm asking you i don't have this
answer i'm not a woman i mean to me i
just feel like
not a lot of labeling just let it happen
you know let them embrace their
masculinity and you
make them or bring their masculinity i
mean i'm seeing that right now with my
with my boyfriend he's honestly never
looked better never felt better never
doing better
since he has got with me
is that because of you and i'm not
saying it's 100 because of me but the
focus is there right so when you have
the same focus and you have the same
goal yeah it's so much faster to reach
it with two people
the same goal than when we're not so i
think it's you help one another it's
it's inevitable like it it's no other
way either you grow or you stay steady
right and i don't want to be with people
who stay steady i always want to grow so
you have to have somebody who always
[Music]